c'est une magnifique journée
et le président est très fier de vous
vous vous êtes très bien comportée
pendant la séance photo et pour vous
remercier
il vous a réservé une petite surprise
certains d'entre vous vont partir faire
un merveilleux voyage scolaire
amusez vous bien le grand nettoyage
enfin commencer nous allons recycler
tous les enfants l'est du pays
désolé monsieur le président mais
n'est-ce pas de la discrimination je
fiche le camp
je croyais que vous aviez dit que vous
les enfants lèvres était enfermée on les
a presque tous attrapé alors pourquoi ce
gosse compte autant on va montrer que
les enfants sont dans un camp
d'internement
on va prouver qu'ils nous ont tous menti
temps déjà une idée
toi montent la garde nantua ain montent
la garde à la tâche
ban
[Musique]